This is Nobel prize in chemistry has as usual been given to three
people,
but one person has won half the Nobel prize.
And the other two show the other half the Nobel prize is
based upon the idea of exploiting evolution
in bacteria,
in other biological systems to make chemicals,
to make pharmaceuticals. That would be very difficult to make. In other ways.
Half of it went to this fantastic researcher called Francis Arnold she's in
Caltech in California,
and has been a major success for the community of
enzymology and Talia.
The other half was split between, uh, George Smith. And so Gregory winter,
they were awarded the prize for the development of a technique called phage
display.
I only know really something about one half of the Nobel prize.
That's the one, one by Francis Arnold.
Her main thing is the, um,
development of techniques that have been applied to enzymes to change their
capacity properties and the quality.
To find ways of changing enzymes,
the natural catalysts that catalyze most of the
processes in our bodies and in all living organisms,
how to change those enzymes so that they will do chemical
reactions that we would really like to be done. For example,
for making biofuels, for making other chemicals that we need.
And then she has screening methods to see which of the Newtons that she's
generated will survive the new condition that she's put in the enzyme.
They take DNA in a gene,
which makes an enzyme that sort of does the reaction you want
and randomly mutate the DNA so that it makes
changes and makes a slightly different enzyme.
So you get lots and lots of different enzymes from one set of
mutations,
and then you try all of those enzymes for the
reaction you want.
Her major expertise is with this enzyme called cytochrome P four 50.
An oxidative type of enzyme is a hymn based enzyme that she can manipulate
with an ease and an elegance that is, uh, Israeli.
And you select the enzyme or few enzymes that do the reaction a
bit better than the natural one.
Chicken grow them in the lab. She can manipulate the DNA very efficiently,
and then she screens for variants that she, um,
is interested in because they're doing the reaction that she's.
And then you go round and round and round each time to choose the
best enzymes that you produce. And after a few generations,
you can produce an enzyme that the reaction you want very,
very much better.
Chemists with all these amazing machinery and labs and all these things you do.
And yet it seems like in the end,
a lot of the time you just use nature to do what you want to do like this nature
still the best at it.
Absolutely. That's exactly.
Actually one of Frances definition that is nature is the best chemist.
The point is that bacteria can make these enzymes very easily.
That generations rotate very quickly.
And once you've got the enzyme identified the modified one that
can do it, it is then very easy to produce it in large amounts.
Well, certainly I thought that she would have,
she was very close to getting the Nobel prize because of all this innovation.
She's also an excellent person like her. She's a lovely person.
She has quite a nice, quite has evolved quite vigorously.
I would say in her career, she's a woman and she's an engineer.
And I think she was the first professor in engineering in college.
And she's a really impressive example of somebody who is both a scientist and
engineer who is combining engineering principles
and scientific principles to do something that's never been done before.
Fewer females in science. Unfortunately,
this is something we are really trying to change. Um,
and the community is becoming very attentive to this situation as well.
So the fact that she was a woman was amazing,
but the fact that she was a woman in my field of research,
that was really what made before me, you know, so it was a great recognition,
a great boost to the field. And, um,
maybe also sparking attention from other scientists in, uh,
peripheral fields to enzyme engineering that I now become interested. So yes,
being a female was amazing. And then it combined that on with that research
can be any better.
She's the only the fifth woman to ever to win the Nobel prize in
chemistry.
And I'm pleased to say that two of those women have won the Nobel prize
during the time we've been making periodic videos.
How did you find out that she'd won the Nobel prize? Where were you,
what were you doing?
I was doing a PhD vibe and I got a text message
from one of my former PhD students and said, you know, fast as Adam did it.
And I was in the Vive.
I couldn't really do anything other than checking it on my unit. I watch.
And I was like, God, I really need to check this out.
And I had to finish until know, wait until the end of the Bible.
They exploited a virus. I've got a model here. My, my empty bottle,
I'm a pipe cleaner. So they, they, um,
exploited a virus called a bacteria phage.
And it's a very simple biological structure.
And it's composed of protein coat, which is represented by the bottle, uh,
which has many different proteins that are assembled together into this.
What's called a capsid internal to this capsid is, um, Australian of DNA.
So genetic material that, um, codes for the proteins of.
The coat, it has the ability to,
and the information encoded within it to replicate itself.
But it can't do that on its own. It has to ha has to do this with bacteria.
And so the bacteria phage can infect bacteria with its DNA
and the bacteria is forced to use its cellular machinery to,
to read and decode the DNA and produce all of the proteins that are involved in
the, in the coat. And so within the bacteria,
the protein coat forms around the file DNA,
and then the bacteria face break out of the bacteria and then can scuttle off
and, and then infect more bacteria. And that's their life cycle.
That's all it does. It goes,
it goes into the bacteria and then the bacteria doesn't just make one copy of
the, of the capsule. It just keeps going.
It keeps making them until they burst out. So from, I don't know how many, uh,
bacteria phase you're made from, from one piece of DNA, but it's it's many.
So it, all it does is reproduce and then kill the backup. That's his job.
It doesn't seem like a nice dude. No, it's not.
Forest is not particularly friendly. So George Smith, one of the recipients.
So he was the first to exploit the,
the relationship between the bacteria phage and the bacteria.
And so he forced the bacteria to make a bacteria phage, which, which had,
um, a protein of interest,
a different protein attached to the top of the protein coat to the capsule.
So I've got my little, my little bespoke protein here.
He did this by inserting a gene.
So the DNA codes for the specific protein.
And so when the bacteria read and decode this DNA,
they'll produce all of the proteins that make up the capsid,
but the heal they'll also produce, uh, this new bespoke protein. Uh,
and so the gene for this protein is inserted into another gene within
the viral DNA.
So he's produced a bacteria phase that displays this bespoke, uh,
protein at the top.
He was forcing the bacteria to express bacteria phage with small fragments of
proteins at the top. And these fragments are antigenic,
which means they can be recognized by the immune system.
And so if we have an infection,
we can an immune response in our body and the body produces larger proteins
called antibodies.
And these can be engineered by our body to bind to pretty much any protein
sequence. And so these little fragments can be recognized by antibodies.
And so you can use the structure now, so he can take a known antibody,
which will bind to this peptide and he can then fish this whole bacteria Faraj,
but here phase out of solution.
The reason for this is that what makes this a fantastic technique is he's now
plucked out, uh, the peptide that binds to the antibody,
but he also has importantly the genetic information that codes for this peptide.
So he can then see what peptide is produce, what protein is produced, um,
from a certain gene and also which peptide or protein binds to the
antibody. And in fact,
the weather sort of healthcare aspect really comes in is with a sir Gregory
winter who took this technology further. And so we just talked about antibodies.
He inserted genes, that code for antibodies into the,
the phage DNA. And so he,
the bacteria would produce the bacteria phage with antibodies attached to the
surface attached to the capsid. Okay. So once you formed your,
your bacteria phage with your antibody there, that's fantastic that you can,
you can produce that.
But th one of the really genius aspects of this research is the ability to
produce billions of different antibodies on top of these phages. And,
and this is done by, uh, making small mutations of the gene,
that codes for the antibody that's been inserted into the bacteria phage.
And so this is actually quite easily done.
And so a gene is a small section of DNA, which has made up as a polymer,
which has made up of many subunits called nucleotides.
And so you may have a few thousand or many thousand nucleotides in one gene.
And so the sequence of nucleotides is very specific and it codes for a very
specific protein. And so just by making very small changes in the sequence,
you're mutating that sequence.
And then you make very small changes in the protein that it codes for.
Okay, so you can make all of these,
you can be taped the DNA and in one pot have many,
many billions of different mutated sequences,
because there are so many nucleotides by making small changes. So for instance,
you could, you could, um,
develop an antibody that binds to a specific target protein.
So let's say if you had a protein that was on the surface of a cancer cell,
that you wanted to bind an antibody to, um, what, uh,
Greg winter did was immobilize that target protein on a solid
surface. So what you can do is you can, uh,
wash all of the many billions of fish with the different antibodies, uh,
across the,
the solid support or they'll bind to the target protein and there'll be
retained. And all the other, um, bacteria fiber will be washed away.
And then you can isolate the ones that bind,
and you don't need to analyze the protein material because you have the genetic
instructions already within the capsid.
So you can take that DNA and you can, um, you can produce, uh,
many more of this particular phage. And then if you repeat the process,
a number of times,
what you're left with is only the few antibodies that bind incredibly strong
that have a very high affinity with the target protein.
And these are the proteins that make the best, the most effective drugs.
Hi, thanks for watching. We've done lots of other videos about Nobel prizes,
previous winners, or just interesting stuff about the prize in general,
if you'd like to check out a playlist of videos,
there should be a link on the screen right now,
or have a quick look down in the video description.